c'est en présence du Recteur de la
réunion des élus du conseil général et
du maire du tampon que Nassima Dindar a
inauguré le collège du 12e au tampon un
collège flambon nef qui accueille depuis
la rentrée dernière des élèves de 6e et
5e c'est un moment émouvement c'est un
moment de joie parce que dans la vie
d'élu rares sont les occasions malgré
tout d'être très heureux et et puis
c'est un moment de respons ité parce que
je crois que nous portons à la Réunion
en matière d'éducation une un vrai enjeu
et et un combat mené depuis la
départementalisation et quand nous élus
nous coupons des rubans sur un
78e collège avec des regards joyeux des
équipes éducatives des enseignants
formés et puis le partenariat entre
l'État les collectivités une commune 20
millions d'investissements de la
collectivité pour permettre à terme à
900 élèves d'intégrer cette nouvelle
structure pour le maire du tampon il
s'agit d'un établissement des plus
modernes du K a aujourd'hui son collège
c'est un établissement qui est considéré
comme étant un établissement des plus
modernes et que donc là nous ensemble
qu'à la première rentrée mais lorsque il
fonctionnera à pleine vitesse il sera à
peu près à 900 étudiants 900 élèves et
donc cela correspond bien à nos besoins
et puis après il faudra envisager de
préparer le prochain terrain pour
accueillir un autre collège le collège
du 12e qui s'inscrit également dans
l'intégration de l'autre puisqu'une
classe ulice sera accueillie il s'agit
d'enfants en situation de handicap une
salle aménagée spécialement pour cet
accueil et un collège doté d'un
ascenseur pour faciliter leur
déplacement il ne s'agit pas seulement
de Tiss mais audelà des classes ULIS
avec un vrai accompagnement et un
partenariat avec laadapi oui je crois
que nous avons encore dans le domaine de
l'accueil des élèves en situation de
handicap encore beaucoup de travail à
faire mais rectorat éducation nationale
et nous-même nous y travaillons chaque
jour pour améliorer avec le partenaire
de la MDPH et les conditions d'accueil
en milieu ordinaire pour ses élèves une
structure totalement moderne des
aménagement de salle avec du matériel
informatique un CDI coloré et beaucoup
d'espace pour permettre aux élèves de
profiter de leur moment de détente le
collège du 12e est un exemple en terme
de qualité environnementale une
structure qui fait le bonheur des
enfants bah il est formidable on mange
bien les profs ils sont hyper
chaleureux bah voilà avec les nouvelles
install avec toutes les nouvelles
installations les nouveaux terrains le
gymnase les classes et voilà professur
cane la cantine elle est bien et B c'est
chouette parce qu'il est neu il est
pas il a un ascenseur il est génial il
est très beau il est neu donc du coup il
y a pas les grands qui sont là pour nous
embêter il y a la nouvelle peinture on
éta les premers à rentrer a une nouvelle
choses on a des Tabl neu des chaises
neues des livr neues et voilà quoi c'est
neu c'est
joli le collège du 12e accueille
actuellement 400 élèves une autreig de
l'établissement proposer aux élèves de
quitter leur cours d'art plastique pour
se rendre par une porte qui donne sur la
terrasse histoire de s'inspirer de la
superbe vue pour éveiller leur esprit
créatif